well whether you're a motorcycle
enthusiast or looking to get on two
wheels for the first time
red rock harley-davidson has got so many
incredible bikes jc fernandez
is live with a cool two-seater that he
picked out for he and ted
yeah that's right kirsten i've got a
perfect two seaters ted and i we're
gonna hit the road this summer and this
here is a very special bike
steve with red rock harley this bike
kind of inspired sons of anarchy sons of
anarchy bike yeah it's a
2021 lowrider s it's a performance
oriented motorcycle
it's got all really cool features the
milwaukee 8 114 inch motor
we've added saddlebags to this bike it's
got the inverted forks on the front
a lot of performance parts on this
motorcycle it just looks cool
it's the sons of anarchy bike i got my
my vest i'm ready to go
now this is the sons of anarchy bike
lance swing around because this
is the cadillac of bikes you guys check
this bike out another two seater for me
and ted to ride on
but look at the uh the dash is it a
dashboard on a motorcycle yeah it's got
a navigation on this bike it's got
bluetooth
and there's your phone this is a 2021
ultra limited
this is what my daily rider is uh it's
very comfortable bike
i've done as much as a thousand miles in
24 hours they call them iron butts
you ride 24 hours and you ride a
thousand miles now it's raining it was
snowing did you ride your bike here
today
i did not ride today because it was not
smart to ride in the rain
that's why i've been stuck in the rain
before so we've all ridden there
let's go over to this one here because
i'm gonna get on a bike uh and start one
up here because you guys offer classes
here at red rock harley
and they're four days when the classes
start we our classes we have weekend
and weekday classes first night runs for
three hours from
six to nine pm the first day of class
then you come in the next day you're
here from about seven to three
and the third day is about seven to
about two in the afternoon that
completes everything you need for the
state of nevada to get your motorcycle
endorsement you've tried
it writing tests your written tests
let's get this thing started all right
all right all right so we're starting a
bike here so what is this what are they
sitting on what's it called
it's called a jump start time we
encourage all our new students to come
in if you've never
shifted gears before or drove a manual
transmission then this is a great way to
practice
your left hand pull the clutch in got
the clutch in okay all right
push that button and it will bring this
harley davidson motorcycle to life here
we go
yeah i like it nothing like that
how can i can i put it in gear yeah so
go ahead and let you let that left hand
out slowly release your clutch hand
slowly release the clutch
the clutch you'll see the back wheel
start to turn feel it
[Music]
that's fun now look how do i turn it off
i'm just sitting here stationary on a
harley davidson
and it's you know just stationary i feel
the power between my legs pretty
exhilarating this is amazing i can
imagine being on the open road
steve you guys offer classes for
beginners to an expert that just wants
to kind of polish up their skills
they offer it all thank you wherever
you're at in your journey we got you
we're here at red rock harley we're here
for the customer whatever it is you need
you know we're here for you awesome well
we're gonna send it back to you guys in
the studio and uh i think i'm gonna go
bike shopping
yeah you really should you should jc
that bike suits you it's a beautiful
bike so
we think you'll be there for several
more hours this is a pretty one
our